[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg schönen guten Abend ihnen
allen und willkommen zum
Nachrichtenüberblick an diesem Mittwoch
die vom Sport hat Norbert Lehmann einen
schönen guten Abend
Hilfe in der Energiekrise
eu-kommissionschefin von der Leyen will
Milliarden übergewinne von Konzernen
abschöpfen um die Menschen zu entlasten
stiller Abschied in London
hunderttausende kommen zur
trauerprozession von Queen Elizabeth II
und mitreißender Sieg Deutschland
gewinnt sensationell gegen Griechenland
und steht im Halbfinale der Basketball
em
[Musik]
die bevorstehenden Monate werden nicht
leicht wir werden auf die Probe gestellt
sagte eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der
Leyen heute in ihrer Rede zur Lage der
EU Putins Krieg sei nicht nur ein Krieg
gegen die Ukraine sondern auch ein Krieg
gegen unsere Wirtschaft unsere Werte und
unsere Zukunft als notfallinstrument
gegen die hohen Energiepreise will von
der Leyen Unternehmensgewinne
umverteilen mehr als 140 Milliarden Euro
Isabel Schäfers nur in blau-gelb kommt
man heute aufs Foto einige
eu-kommissarinnen zeigen so ihre
Solidarität mit der Ukraine und mit der
ukrainischen First Lady Olena selenska
die hört wohl genau zu als Ursula von
der Leyen weitere Unterstützung für ihr
Land verspricht
die europäische Solidarität mit der
Ukraine wird unerschütterlich bleiben ab
Tag 1 stand Europa an der Seite der
Ukraine mit Waffen mit finanzieller
Unterstützung mit Gastfreundschaft
gegenüber Flüchtlingen und mit den
härtesten Sanktionen die die Welt je
gesehen hat
aber schnell wird klar die EU ist vor
allem mit ihrer eigenen Krise
beschäftigt die kommissionspräsidentin
nutzt ihre Rede um deutlich zu machen
dass Europa etwas tun will gegen die
hohen Strompreise bisher wird der
Strompreis in Europa vor allem vom
teuren Gas bestimmt die Produktion von
Strom etwa aus erneuerbaren
Energiequellen oder aus Atomkraft ist
wesentlich günstiger der Verkaufspreis
richtet sich aber nach dem teuren Strom
so entstehen derzeit bei einigen
Stromproduzenten ungewöhnlich hohe
Gewinne sogenannte zufallsgewinne diese
sollen nun teilweise abgeschöpft werden
um damit Haushalte und Firmen zu
entlasten Stromproduzenten sollen
künftig maximal 180 Euro pro
Megawattstunde bekommen so der Plan der
Kommission
in diesen Zeiten ist es falsch
außergewöhnlich hohe Gewinne zu machen
und vom Krieg zu profitieren auf dem
Rücken unserer Verbraucher
es gehe dabei um rund 140 Milliarden
Euro der Tenor im Parlament im Prinzip
richtig aber auf die konkrete Umsetzung
komme es an wir sind vor allen Dingen an
der Lage wo die Märkte nicht mehr
funktionieren ich glaube da kann man zu
drastischen befristeten Maßnahmen
greifen um Gaspreis und Strompreis zu
trennen ich halte das für richtig bei
den Zahlen wenn ich sowieso erstmal
skeptisch da wollen wir mal sehen wie
mutig die Staaten sind um wirklich das
Geld von den großen Unternehmen
einzunehmen Ursula von der Leyen reist
in der Nacht nach Kiew doch ihre Rede
hat gezeigt die größten
Herausforderungen warten diesen Winter
für Sie in Brüssel
diese Gewinnabschöpfung ist bislang erst
ein Plan der Kommission Isabel Schäfers
in Straßburg wie stehen die
Mitgliedsländer dazu
ja diese Vorschläge der Kommission
liegen schon eine Weile auf dem Tisch
und die Energieminister haben darüber
letzte Woche auch bereits beraten und
dort wurde klar das abschöpfen dieser
zufallsgewinne und das umverteilen das
stößt auf eine breite Zustimmung schon
alleine weil viele Mitgliedstaaten einen
ähnlichen Mechanismus bereits etabliert
haben oder geplant haben wie er auch in
Deutschland mit dem Entlastungspaket
ebenfalls auf eine breite Zustimmung
Stößen die stromsparziele von bis zu
zehn Prozent allerdings wird sich hier
die Frage stellen wie verbindlich diese
Ziele am Ende bleiben
umstritten ist allerdings die Idee einen
Deckel für den Preis von russischem Gas
festzulegen das ist vor allem in den
osteuropäischen Staaten stark umstritten
am Ende kann man wohl sagen dass Ende
des Monats die Energieminister sich auf
ein Paket einigen werden was relativ nah
an den jetzigen Vorschlägen der
Kommission sein wird aber dann bleibt
immer noch die Frage wie und vor allem
wie schnell diese Vorschläge dann
umgesetzt werden Dankeschön für diese
Einschätzung nach Straßburg Isabel
Schäfers war das
was kann man tun damit die Energiepreise
nicht ins Unermessliche steigen darüber
berieten heute auch die Energieminister
der Bundesländer mit dabei der Chef der
Bundesnetzagentur Klaus Müller der sieht
überraschend positive Entwicklungen beim
Gaspreis aus Hannover Elisabeth Schmidt
die gute Nachricht zuerst die deutschen
Gasspeicher sind mittlerweile zu mehr
als 88% gefüllt deutlich mehr als im
vergangenen Jahr auch deshalb weil die
Industrie bereits 20% weniger
energieverbrauche sagt der Chef der
Bundesnetzagentur heute in Hannover die
Unsicherheit auf dem Energiemarkt gehe
langsam zurück das Gas was wir
eingespeichert haben wird jetzt auch
demnächst wieder angeboten und in den
Markt zurückgegeben werden das
organisieren wir jetzt schon über
sogenannte Futures das heißt man weiß im
Winter ist das Gas auch wieder zur
Verfügung ich hoffe dass das
Preiseffekte haben wird und zwar nach
unten die Energieminister trotzdem
beunruhigt denn der Gaspreis ist heute
zunächst wieder leicht gestiegen wenn
nicht noch vor Weihnachten massivst die
Energie Preise gesenkt werden für die
Unternehmen respektive die hohen
Energierechnungen teilweise vom Staat
bezahlt werden dann machen die dicht wir
fordern vom Bund eine energiepreisdeckel
beim Gas muss eine Begrenzung des
Preises stattfinden und zwar direkt an
der Quelle wo der Preis entsteht und
nicht bitte bei jedem einzelnen und bei
den Unternehmen die zunächst gar nicht
in der Lage sind es zu zahlen es ist der
Versuch der Geschlossenheit auf
Länderebene der parteiübergreifende
Streit über eine Laufzeitverlängerung
der Atomkraftwerke sei nicht zielführend
ich möchte auch sagen und betonen dass
es nicht so sein darf dass wir
Scheindebatten führen in dem Sinne dass
die Atomenergie alle unsere Probleme
löst wir wollen dass es eine
solarpflicht in Deutschland gibt für
alle Neubauten und bei grundlegenden
Sanierungen sie können auf solche
langfristigen Ziele nicht warten Bäcker
leiden zurzeit besonders unter den hohen
Energiepreisen hunderte fordern heute in
Hannover schn finanzielle Hilfen von
Bund und Ländern
in die militärischen Erfolgsmeldungen
der Ukraine rund um harkev mischen sich
erschütternde Berichte über Folter und
andere Verbrechen der russischen
Besatzer in den zurückeroberten Dörfern
machen ukrainische Armee und
Staatsanwaltschaft nach eigenen Angaben
schreckliche Entdeckungen heute reiste
Präsident selenski in die Region
Kristina gründgen Bilder aus einer
Polizeistation in balaclia südöstlich
von rakev über Monate sollen die
russischen Truppen hier Menschen
gefangen gehalten und gefoltert haben an
den Wänden zählten die Gefangenen die
Tage er sei gefoltert worden nur weil er
ein Foto seines Bruders in Uniform besaß
erzählt einer
ich musste zwei Kabel an einem
elektrischen Generator halten je
schneller sie an dem kurbelten desto
höher wurde die Stromspannung sie haben
gekurbelt und gekurbelt und gefragt sie
haben gesagt ich würde lügen und immer
weitergemacht heute ein
Überraschungsbesuch Präsident selensky
besucht bei La clia gedenkt der Opfer
und dankt Soldaten im ebenfalls
befreiten isium wird im Beisein des
Präsidenten feierlich die ukrainische
Flagge gehisst überall böte sich nach
dem Abzug der Russen das gleiche Bild so
selensky zerstörte Häuser und Leichen
der Anblick ist schockierend aber es
überrascht mich nicht wir haben die
gleichen Bilder in Butcher gesehen
seit Tagen verschiebt sich die
Frontlinie immer weiter vor allem
Richtung Osten die russischen Truppen
stehen unter Druck eine neue
Verteidigungslinie aufzubauen zum
Beispiel an einem Fluss also sind jetzt
nur mehr wenig Gelände Hindernisse die
man wirklich stark verteidigen kann wenn
es die Russen nicht schaffen hier in den
nächsten Tagen Wochen eine Linie
aufzubauen dann wäre die nächste gut
verteidigbare Linie die alte
kontaktlinie die man vor dem 24 februar
im luganska Oblast inhärtet und das
würde wenn es denn so käme sämtliche
russische Gewinne in der Region nur
hansk seit Kriegsbeginn zunichte machen
doch das ist für die Ukraine bisher nur
eine Hoffnung
zurück nach Deutschland das
Hartz-IV-System abschaffen für diesen
Plan hat das Bundeskabinett grünes Licht
gegeben ab Januar soll es stattdessen
des Bürgergeld geben und das soll
deutlich höher ausfallen der Hartz 4
Regelsatz für Alleinstehende liegt
aktuell bei 449 Euro beim Bürgergeld
sollen es 5002 Euro sein außerdem sind
weniger Sanktionen geplant und eine
Prämie für Fortbildung Frank Buchwald
über die Pläne und die Kritik
Hubertus Heil hat Grund zur Freude Hartz
IV ist Geschichte der Minister zur Feier
des Tages in einem Berliner Jobcenter
das alte Trauma der SPD überwunden
stattdessen nun ein Bürgergeld mit
anderer Zielrichtung mit dem neuen
Bürgergeld schaffen wir die Möglichkeit
im Zweifelsfall erstmal ein
Berufsabschluss nachzuholen und damit
tatsächlich dauerhaften Arbeit zu kommen
und das liefert auch einen Beitrag zur
Fachkräftesicherung halsentwurf sieht
nicht nur mehr Geld für Arbeitslose vor
wer etwa einen Beruf lernt bekommt
Zuschüsse Sanktionen drohen erst nach
einem halben Jahr das schon Vermögen
wird erhöht und wer dazu verdient darf
mehr von seinem Geld behalten für die
FDP besonders wichtig
es lohnt sich sich anzustrengen das war
bei Hartz IV derzeit oft nicht der Fall
das wird beim Bürgergeld anders und
dafür haben wir seit vielen Jahren
gekämpft linke und Sozialverbände
bemängeln hingegen die Regelsätze lägen
immer noch viel zu niedrig kritik kommt
auch von der Union allerdings aus
anderen Gründen
leider wird ja durch diese Entscheidung
des Prinzip befördern und fördern weiter
eingeschränkt das sind zementiert eher
die Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit dass das
ist Arbeitsaufnahme fördert und von
daher der Weg in die falsche Richtung im
Herbst berät der Bundestag über das neue
Bürgergeld bereits im Januar soll es
dann Hartz IV ersetzen
das Kabinett hat noch einiges mehr auf
den Weg gebracht auch aus dem dritten
Entlastungspaket zum Beispiel den
Ausgleich der kalten Steuerprogression
er soll 48 Millionen Bürgern zugute
kommen außerdem will der Bund
Krankenhäuser gesetzlich verpflichtend
für ausreichend Pflegepersonal zu sorgen
jetzt nach London dort ist der Sarg von
Queen Elizabeth II gestern angekommen
nach den Feierlichkeiten in Schottland
heute also der große Abschied in England
am Nachmittag der Beginn des trauerzugs
am Buckingham Palace von dort aus ging
es rund zwei Kilometer durch die
britische Hauptstadt ins
Parlamentsviertel bis zur Westminster
Hall aber tausende Bürger kamen um ihrer
Königin Farell zu sagen glückwalpot
berichtet
es war der Moment auf den die Trauernden
in London seit Tagen gewartet haben der
Sarg mit dem Leichnam der Königin wurde
am Nachmittag vom Buckingham Palast ins
Parlament überführt gefolgt von den vier
Kindern König Charles dem dritten und
seinen Geschwistern sowie den Enkeln der
Monarchin und begleitet von Trauer
Ergriffenheit und Tränen tausende die
zum Teil schon gestern hergekommen waren
um dabei sein zu können ein dank vieler
Britinnen und Briten an die Königin die
sie ein Leben lang begleitet hat ist sie
steht für Beständigkeit sie hat das Land
zusammengehalten es ist unsere
Geschichte seit tausend Jahren haben wir
eine Monarchie Teil unseres Kulturerbes
ein schwieriger Übergang auch für den
neuen König Charles der erinnerte
gestern bei einem Besuch im politisch
sensiblen Nordirland noch einmal an das
große Erbe das die Queen hinterlässt
es war ein Privileg ein so
hingebungsreiches leben wie das meiner
Mutter der Königin erleben zu dürfen
möge es uns allen gel die Aufgaben die
vor uns liegen so hervorragend zu
bewältigen
in Anwesenheit der Königsfamilie wurde
vor einer Stunde im Parlamentsgebäude
Westminster Hallein Gedenkgottesdienst
abgehalten gleich anschließend konnten
die ersten Bürger persönlich Abschied
nehmen von der Königin
ich bin wirklich sehr traurig viel mehr
als ich dachte ich bin aus Neuseeland
sie war auch meine Königin
tausende warten noch draußen in der
Schlange bis Montag früh werden sie noch
Gelegenheit haben am Sarg der Monarchin
vorbeizudefinieren
Andreas Stamm in London die Menschen
nehmen hier einiges auf sich um der
Queen noch mal nah zu sein
ja absolut seit etwas mehr als einer
Stunde dürfen die Menschen am Sarg der
Queen vorbeiziehen der aufgebahrt wird
hinter mir im Palace of Westminster dem
britischen Parlamentsgebäude und das ja
die das die Behörden warnen
verwartezeiten von mehr als 30 Stunden
eine kleine Tasche darf man mitbringen
mit etwas essen und trinken viel mehr
ist es nicht und trotzdem lassen sich
die Menschen davon nicht abschrecken
aktuell ist die Länge der Schlange auf
vier Kilometer angewachsen bis zu zehn
Kilometer könnten es sein ja Museen wie
die weltberühmte Tate Britain und Tate
Modern öffnen länger damit die Menschen
auf der Wegstrecke die Toiletten
benutzen können also ich glaube das ist
eines der deutlichsten Zeichen einen
Sinnbild dafür wie groß die Anteilnahme
ist und wie groß die Bedeutung dieser
Königin für viele Menschen nicht nur für
viele Menschen im Vereinigten Königreich
sondern auch darüber hinaus hier wird
nicht irgendeine Königin verabschiedet
sondern die Queen
danke schön nach London für diese
Eindrücke Andreas Stamm
den weiteren Verlauf der Trauerzeremonie
und die beeindruckendsten Bilder des
Tages zeigen wir Ihnen auch in einem
Live-Blog auf ZDF heute und in unserer
App
die Rettung der Lufthansa mit einem
milliardenschweren Schutzschirm hat sich
für den deutschen Staat ausgezahlt nach
gut zwei Jahren hat der Bund seine
letzten Aktienanteile verkauft mit
deutlichen Gewinn in Höhe von 760
Millionen EURO
2020 hatte der Staat in der corona-krise
den Konzern unter anderem mit einer
Aktienbeteiligung gerettet
bundesinnenministerin Faeser hat die
Rocker ähnliche Gruppierung United
tribbons verboten Mitgliedern des
Vereins werden Sexualstraftaten
Menschenhandel und versuchte Tötung
vorgeworfen mehr als 1.500 Polizeikräfte
durchsuchten Clubs und Wohnungen in
neuen Bundesländern die rund 100
Mitglieder hatten sich auch gewaltsame
Auseinandersetzungen mit anderen
Rockergruppen wie den Hells Angels
geliefert
und jetzt zur Basketball-EM Norbert
Deutschland steht im Halbfinale das ist
ja der Hammer oder absolut da reibt man
sich schon so ein bisschen die Augen
damit hatte vor dem Turnier wohl kaum
jemand wirklich gerechnet wieder ein
bärenstarker mitreißender Auftritt des
deutschen Teams beim 107 zu 96 Sieg in
Berlin gestern Abend im Viertelfinale
gegen Griechenland
dieses deutsche Team hat bewiesen
zusammen ist alles möglich nach
phänomenalem Start haben die Deutschen
Griechenlands NBA-Star erntete Kumpel
regelrecht entzaubert Kapitän Dennis
Schröder glänzte mit Spielwitz schnellen
Angriffen und 26 Punkten zu Beginn des
dritten Viertels gelang den Deutschen
sogar ein 20:1-lauf auch die Defensive
und ein mit 16 Rebounds überragender
Daniel
107 zu 96 Sieg
Nacht waren wir gut aber es ist vorbei
wir blicken nach vorn wir haben ein Ziel
und das wollen wir erreichen
am Freitag geht es um Halbfinale dann
gegen Spanien
zur Fußball Champions League und zum
ersten Sieg der Eintracht in der
Königsklasse gestern Abend in Marseille
überschattet wurde der Frankfurter 1:0
Erfolg durch heftige Ausschreitungen
zwischen sogenannten Fans aus beiden
Lagern
die Feuerwerkskörper flogen zwischen den
beiden Fanblöcken hin und her ein
Frankfurter Anhänger wurde schwer
verletzt bei der UEFA stand die
Eintracht bereits unter Beobachtung nun
könnten Sanktionen wieder Ausschluss des
Publikums beim nächsten Spiel folgen
das ist ein Stück weit ein rechtsfreier
Raum den wir da feststellen mussten auf
der Seite von den Olympic Fans
wir müssen einräumen dass es auch in
unseren Reihen welche gab die das gerne
angenommen haben der Eintracht gelegt in
Marseille ein historischer eins zu 0
Sieg der Däne jetzt bei Lindström nutzt
kurz vor der Pause einen Abwehrfehler es
ist der erste Sieg von Eintracht
Frankfurt in der Champions League
neben der Eintracht waren auch die
beiden anderen deutschen Vereine gestern
Abend siegreich leverkusen gewann 2:0
gegen Atletico Madrid ja und ebenso die
Bayern zu Hause gegen Barcelona bin 3
Minuten macht um München alles klar
durch die Tore von Lukas amandis in der
51 und durch Leroy sané in der 54 Minute
nach seinem herrlichen solo-lauf durch
die wasserabwehr
ja und heute Abend spielen noch Dortmund
und Leipzig alle Begegnungen
zusammengefasst zu sehen bei uns später
im Champions League Magazin Sportstudio
Champions League heißt es genau
23:15 Uhr 23:15 Uhr
danke schön und jetzt noch eine wichtige
Info für alle Lottospieler und Lotto
Spielerinnen die Gewinnzahlen des
heutigen Tages lauten
2 9 11 16 39 48 und die Superzahl 5
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
557 das Wetter morgen wird sehr nass
teilweise gewittrig die Details hat
gleich Christa orbben Anne gerlinek
freut sich auf Sie im heute journal um
Viertel vor elf und hier übernimmt
morgen wieder mit risirin ich wünsche
Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend sehr markant heute war
dieser Streifen mit Dauerregen von
Nordrhein-Westfalen bis nach Sachsen
diese Luftmassengrenze trennt kühle Luft
im Norden von sehr milder Luft im Süden
und in genau dieser feuchten milden Luft
in der es in Rosenheim heute noch mal 28
Grad gab bilden sich jetzt seit dem
Nachmittag teils schwere Gewitter mit
Hagel Starkregen und Sturmböen und auch
heute Nacht ist das weiter möglich
achten Sie also auf die Warnungen des
Deutschen Wetterdienstes insgesamt
rutscht das Regenband weiter südlich in
der Nacht sonst meist trocken außer
einzelne Schauer die an der Nordsee
unterwegs sind die Temperaturen sinken
aufs neun Grad in den Mittelgebirgen und
17 Grad am Oberrhein morgen gibt es in
der Mitte und im Norden ähnliche
Temperaturen wie heute im Süden ist es
aber mit nur noch maximal 22 Grad
deutlich kühler und genau hier sind auch
die gewittrigen Regenschauer morgen
südlich des Mains noch unterwegs teils
weiter mit Starkregen ansonsten oft
wechseln heute nachmittags an der
Nordsee dann einzelne Schauer und dazu
dieser kräftige Westwind und der bringt
uns am Wochenende auch deutlich kühlere
Temperaturen dreht dann noch weiter auf
nördliche Richtungen teils nur noch acht
Grad Höchstwerte am alpenrad und dazu
ist es unbeständig und regnerisch das
war es von uns tschüss